the air is thick with smoke and it's
hard to breathe the military are now on
the ground in the state of Rondonia
which has been hardest hit by the
Blazers as soon as one fires under
control the next one breaks out huge
areas now resemble a lunar landscape
safale see a pendulum for ku
if there were just one or two big fires
we could deal with them better than all
the small ones manager whose
headquarters
there have been widespread protests
since the fire started on Friday under
international pressure Brazil's
president Jaya bowls narrow deployed
soldiers to the region to fight the
blazes Brazil has said it will accept
aid from Israel and Argentina but both
anaru responded sharply to a pledge of
20 million dollars from g7 leaders on
Twitter he accused French President
Manuel Michael of having a colonialist
attitude towards Brazil do you think
someone gives money without wanting
something in return
why do they have their eye on the Amazon
Guinea scheduler since entering office
both Naro has slashed environmental
protection in the Amazon in a bid to
open up the area to industry and spur
economic growth okay let's get more now
at tea w's Daniel cope he's in
Portobello which is in the Brazilian
state of Adonia we saw it in the report
there now it has been among the worst
hit by the Amazon wildfires a good day
to you Daniel what's it looking like
how's the fight against these wild
blazes coming along yeah there Brian I
can tell you that the fight against
those fires has been extremely difficult
here for fire fighters but also for the
population we heard it in the report
that about 80,000 fires in the entire
Amazon region and we are learning that
just since last Friday about 1200 new
fires have been reported we saw and we
have been talking to firefighters here
from the region there
been telling asset for them it's it's
kind of like a it's kind of like a
mission that for them is a very hard to
manage and we are learning that in many
cities also in big cities here like
photo video with about 500,000 people
firefighters have been kind of giving up
to to manage the situation and let me
also tell you Brian that all of this of
course also affecting the daily life
here of people we have been talking to
local residents a year they've been
sharing with us that because of the bad
air of because of the pollution in the
air right now
because of those fires for them it's
hard to breathe a lady was sharing with
us that already when she wakes up in the
morning as she feels very tired so all
of this is affecting also the local
people here yeah the air pollution is
certainly a big concern for for elderly
people where you are for children for
the sick you don't Daniel there's
there's a question out there reportedly
landowners in this area have themselves
been lighting the fires these that have
turned into these wildfires to clear
land for cattle ranching for agriculture
that's something that balsan our o the
president has been supporting up to now
but given the severity of these fires
could the president change tack on his
approach to these fires could could that
situation change what I personally don't
think that this is going to change
because also these farmers are some of
its big supporters they have been saying
that in the past former Brazilian
President never really paid attention to
the interest of those farmers now
they're seeing that president Basu Nago
is you know having this difference a
strategy that he has been you know
supporting basically that those you know
farmers you know would burn their land
in order you know to have more space
there for for their animals so I don't
really think that this situation is at
the end going to change because this
group are you know his voters that he
will need also in the future okay now
Bolton are oh and Brazil been offered 20
million from the g7 that way
turned down at the same time Boston I
was saying the G sevens treating Brazil
like a colony what's what's been some of
the reactions where you are bow to the
rejecting of the money and anti calling
Brazil or treating Brazil quote like a
colony well the reactions here are
actually very divided in the population
when you talk to supporters of both so
now they do agree they're saying that in
the past Brazil has been listening way
too much to other countries and that it
doesn't work like that when you send
money and then Brazil you know has to
react both oh na who is also very clear
he is saying that you know the amazon
region it's the it's the decision of
Brazil what's going to happen with that
and he is not agreeing with a president
Mac Hong who was saying you know that
the Amazon region basically belongs to
the you know to the world of population
others are of course saying that the
entire attitude that the entire behavior
of Basel now is extremely risky and that
he should accept help financially but
also you know when you talk about
firefighters when you talk about
firefighter training you know from other
countries Daniel thank you very much for
that reporting from Porto Valeo there in
the Brazilian state of Adonia right at
the epicenter of those Amazonian
wildfires thanks very much Daniel